our video of the day comes from Barstool
Sports founder Dave Portnoy who
heroically caught a Washington Post
reporter in a terrible lie it started
when the post Emily Heil emailed
sponsors of an event that he was hosting
asking them to comment on what she
called his problematic Behavior but Port
Noy got a hold of that email and
confronted her over the phone roll it
we have this pizza Fest happening on
Saturday and you're reaching out to our
advertisers and you're basically sending
an email that says to the effect Dave's
a misogenic racist do you want to defend
yourselves advertising at this event
right no I'm not I'm not I haven't said
anything like that if you want I can
read what you actually sent I have it
yeah we because I sent a bunch of notes
so I want to make sure I know which one
okay uh we are planning to write about
the festival and how and how some of the
sponsors and participants have drawn
criticism by seemingly to associate
themselves with Dave Portnoy who has a
history of misogenic comments and other
problematic Behavior I want to make sure
that blank had a chance to respond to
this since the company is the most
prominent and their partners of his
Festival
oh that's the one I sent you which was
definitely the most pointed of them
because I really did want them to
respond and I was hoping to get
something from them
how misogenic
I don't know what that means but what a
sweet glorious thing you see exposed
exactly how reporters work create the
conclusion and work backward and enter
the reporting conversation with your
assumption portrayed as an accepted fact
in her mind that makes Dave a misogynist
or as he calls it misogenic cat you
actually were a reporter for bar stool
at one point I guess if you could you
call it report I was a reporter you went
to the Insane Clown Posse uh what was it
called yeah the Gathering of the
Juggalos yes yes and barcel was a lot
smaller then so it was literally just me
and the camera guy who had like salmon
colored shorts on like walking around
there uh yeah no I know Dave I actually
interviewed Dave for the saturday night
show on Fox News
um I think it's really funny how she
tried to say uh you know well I didn't
reach out to you because we kind of
wanted to figure out what we were going
to write first and what this is going to
be about as if there was any Nuance in
that email yeah the email was like so
Dave Portnoy you're working with him he
is a piece of sh yeah explain yourself
thank you and that was the entire email
and she had it and she kept trying like
it would have been better if she would
have just been like yeah you know what I
don't like you and this is a hit piece
yeah because the email says it all yeah
exactly you know Chris this wasn't about
writing a story it was a strategy to
scare the advertisers away yes that's
100 what it was and I love Dave Portnoy
I mean he literally is completely
Fearless he's just like I don't care
cancel me don't like he's gonna do what
he thinks is right and I applaud I mean
he's got bigger balls than a
spokesperson for Ukraine yeah he really
is like
unbelievable and I I love I love Dave
Portnoy and uh you know I love to work
for Barstow but they don't return emails
yeah that's true at the endings don't
forget
the rule here is tape the conversations
take the conversations well because
journalism is dead they it was a cancel
piece we're gonna cancel it because
because they don't like him yeah because
he's doing I interviewed him for a show
before and he's he's from Boston so
you're going to get that Boston attitude
yeah you know what I'm saying and it
came out of him the only thing he was
like this wicked personal like yeah you
know and I love when they stutter like
which which note was it yeah
my next question would have been how
many did you say yeah
saying that I was a misogynistic monster
because here's the thing when you go to
somebody and be like you sir with a
Yankee hat on uh how many people did
Tyrus kill that you were aware of yeah
you're gonna be like well I was uh maybe
one I don't know so you do know he
killed somebody well I guess so well
then they on the record and that's what
they're doing by saying he this happened
and somebody will all of a sudden well I
heard that he's rude yeah you know and
then then they'll take that and stretch
it that's exactly what they wanted like
you know I he doesn't he he assaults
children yeah he'll just extract just
drag it out and drag it out make the
cover everyone looks at it and hope the
the the ad companies will be like oh we
can't be a part of this we're hearing a
lot of talk about murder yeah a pizza
Festival this guy raises Millions he
makes small businesses money
to prove him wrong right but he doesn't
have to do this yeah he's not broke yeah
he's not trying to be the next Little
Caesar yeah I'm saying like he did
something he does for the community
but see he's really doing it yeah so we
didn't get a chance you know she wanted
to write about feelings because you can
say anything with it yeah and she's a
food writer Aaron I saw you almost jump
out of your seat when you were listening
to that didn't it give you pleasure to
see this happen I loved it send it back
to the journalist what a master class
there one he never goes off the Record
that is a power move in Communications
if you never go off the record with a
reporter they got nothing that they can
use against you if you're out there the
whole time and you can use it on the
record that gives you a position of
power that is sad gotcha journalism from
a food writer who was trying to set him
up and set up the advertisers to be like
you can't have anything to do with this
that's what it looks like when you are
prepared and he brought receipts like it
was a real housewives reunion and he was
ready to read her on it it was fantastic
that is exactly what it looks like when
you should be Unapologetic in your
position I absolutely loved it I enjoy
Barstool Sports I think that not only
are they great content they actually
have some of like the biggest female L
podcast hosts in the country like this
guy works hard and has built a business
and has supported small business and the
Washington Post tried to take him down
by taking out his advertisers and Dave
Portnoy I love that he one identified
himself at the top said I was recording
because I can't tell you how many time
times in my industry reporters don't
identify themselves as reporters and
don't tell you they're recording this is
why you always got to be careful when
you answer the phone screen all your
calls yeah I mean to be safe I have I
record everything I have him in the
bathroom that's probably a little much
oh really yeah then I just no no no no
no he needs all of it yeah yes exactly
following the path of that great
journalist Chuck Berry
but you know most people the thing is
most people don't have the I guess uh
experience that Portnoy has if you were
just an average Joe you would think the
reporter has his best interests in mind
you know it might be really exciting if
you're just a guy who runs a restaurant
gets a call and I'm supposed to be
impressed best and so I don't think that
this guy is going to screw me over and
she was also like Dave oh yeah Dave Dave
portno yeah oh yes I yeah I think I know
who that is like come on yeah who admits
what she's doing there when she says
like well yeah that was my most pointed
one like she is really trying to Goat
people into giving as big a reaction as
possible and like people who don't work
with reporters that is their mo more
often than not they they work their
entire story they get to the very end
and then they're like okay so here's
everything I've gotten that's terrible
especially in a hit piece and they're
like and I need you to respond in two
hours good luck thank you so much it's
it's classic in the journalism industry
and he said it correctly when Dave
Portnoy said this is a sad State of
Affairs for journalists yeah it's a good
thing that we were able to see it coming
up he had the donations rolling by
faking cancer of the colon
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else